laffire cé encore qui rebondit dans le
point people ce mercredi alors on a vu
le témoignage d'hier a énormément fait
parler he Gill de de Ludovic vraiment
beaucoup de gens ont parlé hier
j'aimerais qu'on rappelle ce témoignage
pour nos téléspectateurs à 21h
d'aujourd'hui puisque l'affaire encore
rebondit oui donc c'est le témoignage de
Ludovic qui explique en gros que Julie
n'a pas dit la vérité il dit que Julie a
a menti qu'il n'y a pas eu de viol il
dit aussi que Julie il a il fait passer
Julie pour une personne vénale et puis
il dit également avoir lui eu une
relation intime avec Julie dans une
chambre d'hôtel alors Cyril moi j'ai eu
l'entourage de Julie aujourd'hui euh qui
donc dément formellement
euh une quelconque relation intime entre
Ludovic qui est venu sur le plateau hier
et elle voilà donc ça c'est la première
chose et je alors il aurait donné tous
les éléments à la police on l'a vu même
après hier absolument il a tout donné il
a dit connaissait pas coé aussi hier
d'après mes informations il connait coé
il y a même des vidéos qui surculent
notamment sur une voiture
a alors il a tout donné à la police
apparemment alors je voudrais juste
ajouter aussi une une information euh il
a expliqué que il y aurait eu peut-être
d'autres viols concernant Julie donc
j'ai eu l'entourage de Julie il y a une
autre affaire en cours qui est une
affaire de viol pour laquelle julie a
déposer plainte c'est avec son ancien
employé oui mais qui n'a rien à voir
avec avec le mil justement non mais oui
c'est important dans l'istoire précis il
y a il y a une plainte déposée par
Julie c'est une plainte concernant un
viol une agression dans la rue d'abord
elle aurait été tabassée puis un viol
cette plainte est en instruction elle
n'a pas été jugée voilà d'accord il y a
pas une autre plainte dans alors ça je
ne sais pas ça c'est une info que je
vous donne d'après
toujoursentourage viol concernant julice
les deux seuls oui voilà alors euh s'il
vous plaît oui et il y a une alors et il
y a une 4rième plainte aujourd'hui qui a
été déposée contre Sébastien cohet c'est
sorti aujourd'hui une plainte qui a
priori serait prescrite une plainte qui
date de
1997 une jeune femme de 18 ans qui
affirme qu'elle a été agressée
sexuellement par Sébastien cohet dans un
parking voilà alors c'est c'est c'est
Mathilde he on l'avait déjà son
témoignage avait c'est déjà retranscrit
par le Nouvel Observateur alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que Mathilde elle a
témoigné déjà avant même que Gily prenne
la parole sur les réseaux sociaux en
2022 elle s'était même adressé
directement à cé pour lui dire est-ce
que tu te souviens de ce que tu m'as
fait sur skyrock et et à et à ce est-ce
que tu faisais ça aussi à tes fans on en
parle balance ton avec hashtag
évidemment balance ton port et à
l'époque cohé l'avait l'avait bloqué sur
les réseaux sociaux et donc aujourd'hui
elle a décidé pour pour aider Julie et
puis aussi pour parler et et et dénoncer
ça que de porter plainte même si elle
sait que sa plainte est est forcément
sous le coup de la prescription alors
les avocats de Cé on et on réagit à
cette plainte Gill ils appellent ils
affirment la fausseté des accusations et
appelle à la prudence à cette nouvelle
lur ligne ne dévie pas d'un pouce elle
est celle de Sébastien cohet qui l'a
exprimé dimanche euh tout est faux tout
est mensonger et rappelons également que
Sébastien cé a déposé trois plaintes lui
aussi hein dénonciation calomnieuse
cyber harcèlement avant que l'affaire ne
sorte et extorsion tentative d'extorsion
de fond en bande organisée reste à
savoir maintenant si les avocats de
Sébastien cet vont estimer que cette
4ème plainte entre de dans le cadre de
cette tentative d'extorsion et dernière
info la brigade des mineurs travaille
beaucoup il y avait plusieurs auditions
dans laffire cé aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
oui de nombreux proches ont été ont été
auditionnés parce que pour l'instant il
y a faut quand même rappeler il y a deux
deux plaintes pour viol euh celle de
Julie et du et de et de Sarah et et et
puis deux pour agression sexuelle il y
en a une on ne sait pas qui c'est et
puis mathtide qui dont la plainte est
pour est sous le coup de la prescription
alors on a est-ce qu'on a des nouvelles
de Julie parce que on entend beaucoup de
chosescant Julie quelles sont les
nouvelles alors Julie va pas bien du
tout euh elle vit très mal le le ce
qu'elle estime elle être une défense
très agressive elle ne n'a pas supporté
notamment qu'on qu'on dise d'elle que
elle envoyait des photos de nu à toute
l'équipe enfin elle a l'impression
d'être prise dans une énorme machination
ou des gens alors c'est bizarre parce
que les deux côtés disent sont dans une
machination ex exactement les deux côtés
sont sur la même ligne faux mensonge
donc c'est vraiment deux points de vue
extrêmement antagoniste c'est pour ça
que la brigade des mineurs multiplie les
interventions recueille toute la
téléphonie prend énormément de
précautions et c'est pas un hasard non
plus si c'est la brigade des mineurs qui
travaillent évidemment il y a un viol
présumé qui a été commis sur une mineur
mais c'est la plus silencieuse de toutes
les brigades donc confidentialité
terrible autour de l'enquête mais les
deux versions s'opposent Miriam donc
Julie elle dit que elle c'est elle aussi
elle parle de machination et ben oui
parce qu'elle en fait elle ne sait plus
elle a des gens qui la contactent qui
essayent de lui faire dire des choses
donc elle est sous enregistrement elle
comprend pas des gens qu'elle pensaiit
être ses amis finalement elle se dit bah
peut-être que ce ne sont plus mes amis
et du coup cette cette cette jeune femme
viole ou pas viole on éétait pas là au
moment des faits est une jeune femme
extrêmement fragile elle a quand même
fait cette semaine elle s'est retrouvé
deux fois à l'hôpital pour des
tentatives de suicide moi j'ai vécu ça
en direct avec elle mercredi ça a été
assez pourquo vous avez vu son mais
parce que moi elle m'a envoyé alors je
je sais pas je je la connais pas
personnellement mais comme je je voilà
j'ai j'ai j'ai recueilli son témoignage
comme celui de plusieurs femmes
d'ailleurs et puis j'ai j'ai aussi
beaucoup interviewé l'entourage de Cé et
donc Julie je suis en contact avec elle
et tout d'un coup je reçois à 14h56 un
témoign un texto me disant je je je je
pense que je me que que je m'en sortirai
jamais que non elle dit pas ça elle dit
pas que je m'en sortirai jamais elle dit
elle dit voilà j'ai l'impression que que
tout que que tout le monde est contre
moi que coé va s'en sortir je n'ai
qu'une envie c'est de me mettre lacorde
au coup donc moi elle me si vous voulez
elle me balance ça euh là je suis en
stress total donc pendant une demi-heure
j'essaie de de l'appeler elle ne répond
pas elle ne répond pas elle ne répond
pas et je décide j'appelle des personnes
qu'elle connaît pour voir s'ils ont eu
des nouvelles d'elle et puis bah je me
rends compte que bah personne n' de
nouvelles elle ne répond plus à mes
appels donc je décide d'appeler le 911
et là je remercie énormément les équipes
des pompiers et notamment Éric et la
gendarmerie parce que il se sont d'abord
rendus chez elle pour voir si elle était
là donc là ils s'aperçoivent qu'elle est
pas là et puisque les gendarmes ont fait
je trouve ça assez exceptionnel merci à
eux ils ont borné son téléphone et ils
l'ont finalement retrouvé alors ils
l'ont d'abord retrouvé près de près près
des des voies ferrées et cetera et ils
l'ont retrouvé dans un état pitoyable
cette jeune fille va vraiment mal elle
est détruite par ce qui lui arrive parce
qu'elle a l'impression que tout lui
tombe dessus est-ce que c'est
envisageable que quelqu'un d'ussi
fragile psychologiquement puisse être à
l'origine d'une machination et une
organisation d'extorsion de fond moi moi
sincèrement alors voilà je sais que je
vous donne mon sentiment profond j'ai du
mal à le croire je pense que cette cette
gamine mais att elle est elle est pour
moi elle est manipulée franchement elle
est d'une elle est manipulée par par
d'autres gens voilà elle est d'une elle
elle est elle est assez naïve que disait
ludov elle est assez naïve elle est très
fragile moi je pe je peux pas croire
pour l'avoir entendu pleurer qu'elle
joue la comédie du début jusqu'à la fin
je je je je n'y crois pas alors
peut-être que je suis trop sensible
peut-être que je suis trop empathique
j'en sais rien mais
personnellement moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même faire très attention parce
que cette jeune femme est a vécu des
choses difficile et que aujourd'hui même
si la défense de Cé normal c'est normal
qu'il se défend et qu'il soit très
agressif il y a y a il y a quand même
des vies en jeu et je et je veux
vraiment voilà aler c'est normal que les
uns et les autres se défendent oui mais
bon c'est aussi agressif parce que si
vous voulez il y a des choses qui sont
dites moi j'ai eu quand même accès à pas
mal de choses donc il y a des choses qui
sont dites qui sont pas non plus
totalement vraies et qui sont
dénigrantes pour lui de toute façon dans
cette histoire c'est assez violent parce
que d'un côté comme de l'autre il se
dénigre donc moi ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment que les
enquêteurs aillent très vite sur ce
genre d'affaire en général c'est assez
long mais je crois vraiment qu'il est
important et moi si j'ai quelque chose à
dire c'est qu'ils aille très vite parce
que je ne sais pas combien de temps
euh Julie va tenir et je peux vous le
dire elle va très mal donc il faut
vraiment faire attention et euh et moi
je suis inquiète pour elle oui euh
d'après le l'entourage de Sébastien cohé
elle pourrait être faire partie de la
manipulation mais d'après nos
informations si je pu dire s'il y a un
manipulateur c'est pas elle le le la
tête pensante de tout ça serait selon
mes infos quelqu'un qui a été
extrêmement proche de Sébastien cohet
qui a travaillé à ses côtés voilà voilà
les infos que peux vous donner voilà
alors oui il faut faut y aller aussi
parce que je sais de qui tu parles mais
effectivement il
C voilà cette personne est en contact
avec avec Julie mais voilà j'ai j'ai moi
j'ai de ce que mais c'est quoi cette
info parce que c'est quoi c'est quoi non
mais l'info ent entre voilà prendre avec
des pincettes comme on dit c'est quoi
c'est qu' un ancien collaborateur de coé
qu' aurait monté une oui exactement vous
avez tout dit vous avez tout dit mais ce
serait non oui au on dit au conditionnel
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est un mec qui
était très proche de lui très proche de
lui c'est c'est pour ça que la plainte
pour tentative d'extorsion de fond en
bande organisée prend sa dimension et
c'est pour ça que ça pourrait remonter à
plusieurs années parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé avec lui il y
a longtemps qui ne travaille plus avec
lui voilà connait très bien la personne
qui a témoigné hier puisqu'il a été son
colocataire donc voilà et puis bon la
personne qui a témoigné hier elle
connaît pas si bien Julie qu'elle a pu
forcément le dire en tout cas selon
Julie selon Julie elle selon Julie elle
ne elle ne le connaî pas tant que ça
elle na effectivement jamais eu
d'histoire d'amour avec lui et moi j'ai
vu des échanges al alors justement parce
que il a montré des échanges à la
production après l'émission ce serait
fou quand même qu'il donne ses échanges
à la police et qui viennent parler ici
sur le plateau parce qu'il a donné tous
les échanges à la police eu le garçon
qui est venu hier donc c'est sinon on
l'aurait jamais pris dans l'émission il
don voilà et les avocats coé ont tous
les éléments que leur a donné euh
Ludovic fou vous avez très bien résumé
des deux côtés on nous dit puisqu'on
travaille avec Myriam là-dessus nous
avons toutes les preuves nous avons tous
les documents nous avons tous les
message nous avons tout enregistré parce
que dans cette histoire tout le monde
enregistre tout le monde dès que vous
interrogez quelqu'un il vous dit mais
j'ai tous les enregistrements j'ai toute
la téléphonie et cetera donc je pense
Myriam que ça va être très long parce
qu'il y a une masse de milliers de
documents message de milliers
d'enregistrements téléphoniques des
versions totalement contradictoires pour
moi cette enquête c'est une enquête au
long cours qui est extrêmement complexe
et vous avez tout résumé deux versions
parfaitement contradictoires que dit
Energie aujourd'hui le alors apparemment
il y a une enquête interne qui se enfin
Energie continue de vouloir tout
examiner et pour le moment pareil selon
mes infos Energie rien trouvé de
répréhensiblei mes infos c'est que
Energie envisagerait quand même de faire
revenir cé dès janvier oui ah oui c'est
c'est un pe donc donc voilà mais donc
donc l'enquête ils ont fini l'enquête
interne eux leur enquête interne voilà
n'a rien donné de spécial et bon comme
coé quand même très important sur cette
radio se passer de lui être assez
compliqué mais il reviendrait en janvier
il reviendrait en janvier mais moi
j'aime aussi dire quelque chose c'est
que aussi dans les infos qu'on a eu
c'est pour ça que le le le
l'interrogatoire des téléphones
portables des uns et des autres va être
très importante parce que il paraîtrait
elles sont deux à le dire que des viols
auraient été filmés donc c'est très
important de que les les enquêteurs
s'emparent rapidement t les éléments des
des des téléphones pour pouvoir faire la
lumière sur cette affaire qui
effectivement est quand même très très
compliquée merci Miriam merci on vous
retrouve sur FR sur paramoun bien sûr
c'est merci à
tous